how you doing chris what's going on my
man how you feeling i'm feeling okay i'm
getting by i'm ready for all this to be
over i'm ready to get out there
uh have fun i know you've been hanging
out is it is your place outside atlanta
is that where it is
no i mean it's south side of atlanta so
you just wanted the suburbs college park
where i grew up and went to school but
yeah you can say that
now now tell me about this you're
hanging out on a pretty substantial
property i don't want you i know you
don't want to brag but i'll brag
on your behalf you've got like 22 acres
is that right
yes i do man and i mean if i was going
to be quarantined anywhere this would
definitely be the place to be
so 22 acres of land i'm able to i don't
know if you know this or not but i have
all women in my household so i have
three daughters all right
no sons i have a wife uh her mother
comes and visits my mother comes to
visit
the only other pair of balls in this
household is the dog and me and him walk
outside every 15 minutes to get away
from all of this estrogen that's in this
household
22 acres of land is great
i got two things to say first i'm
impressed that your dog still has his
balls
uh because that was the first thing to
go um
they took mine when they took my dogs uh
and then the other thing is
i gotta say you got 22 acres
it's perfect like if there was a zombie
apocalypse
i would say get me to chris ludacris
bridge's house i want to hang out there
you've got a secure perimeter right this
is the perfect place to be
absolutely and a dog who will do
anything for me because he wants to get
out of this house full of women just as
much as i do
yeah so yes if anyone comes anywhere
close he's adam believe that
i can't take his balls away because we
the only two with a pair of balls come
on man
i don't want to be the only pair of
balls yeah so so wait a minute so
you've got all these women in the house
do you handle that well
do you like being the only guy or do you
really wish the dog aside there was
another guy hanging around
and are and are you inviting me over is
that's what's happening
you are 100 invited over and to answer
your original question
you know to be honest it's more of an
investment because when you have all
these women
you know later on in life they're going
to take care of you you know what i'm
saying if you have sons what i've heard
is
they don't really give a damn when you
get older but when you have daughters
you get older and they take care of you
so it's an investment so it's something
to look forward to this is what i tell
my
kids all the time sometime in the next
five years you're gonna have to start
carrying me to the toilet
that's and not because i'm in firm just
because i'm too late i'm just gonna go
limp and you gotta
that's your job i've done a lot once i
pay for college you're carrying me to
the toilet that's what's happening
listen
i hope you got some strong kids because
you are one tall mother
i don't know how much you pay but i can
tell you it's gonna be they're gonna
have to carry
a lot of them carrying you god damn it
man yeah i know i gotta it's gonna be
take a lot of people uh now
i understand you've got a tennis court
that you weren't using before
on your property but now here's the
thing i've noticed about
this pandemic we're all starting to do
things we weren't doing before
you started using your tennis court
right bro listen this tennis court and
you can look on my social media if you
want to
the tennis court was just on my property
for like over 10 years just
writing i even had a lyric in a song
where i said my tennis my tennis court
is rotten and i'm waiting
on serena like waiting on cereal serena
williams in order to play yeah so now i
just redid the whole court because
i was bored as hell at home and now i
started playing on it so
i'm loving playing tennis and learning
to the game and uh
i feel like in about a couple weeks or
so i'll be ready for the masters uh
wimbledon whatever you guys want to
throw at right okay
yeah so you're also good at golf because
masters is golf sorry i had to say that
yeah
i had to say that no what i meant to say
was i'm a master
yes i'll be ready for any of the master
there you go
consider themselves as masters in the
tennis game very good
that's a very good save which means you
are ready you have all the requisite
skills uh what about your house i
imagine this is a big house are you
are you using every room in your house
are you finding
like you're using spaces like during
this quarantine i started using my
dining room i wasn't using my dining
room a lot and we would use it but it
was always just for company and now i
try and go in there just because it's a
different space
i'm i'm finding new uses for things let
me let you in on a little secret uh
conan i used every room in this house
before i was married but
i don't want to get in trouble okay so
i'm just gonna i'm gonna leave that
alone yes i i have used every room in
this house
wait okay let me just i don't want to
get you in trouble but when you were a
single man
you used every room in the house oh for
sure
and now that i'm a married man i'm still
using every room in the house
very nice i've even added on rooms in
order to
you know make sure that that we use more
rooms that weren't here before
the whole point
so okay so even before you were using
the tennis court for tennis
you were using the tennis court i was
using the tennis court
for golf because i wanted to go to the
master yeah
i was just hitting a random golf ball on
a rotting tennis court
it was so rotten it would look like
grass that's what i'm trying to tell you
i love it
i love it it all comes together very
nice